aucus es el acrónimo que conjunta los
nombres de los países miembros del pacto
en 2021 Australia Estados Unidos y Reino
Unido acordaron forjar una alianza
estratégica para reforzar la integración
en temas de seguridad y defensa su
principal objetivo sería contrarrestar
la creciente influencia china en la
región
Hoy estamos dando otro paso histórico
para profundizar y formalizar la
cooperación entre nuestras tres naciones
Porque todos reconocemos el imperativo
de garantizar la paz y la estabilidad en
el Indo Pacífico a largo plazo
Australia podría recibir los primeros
submarinos de propulsión nuclear de
fabricación estadounidense a principios
de la década de 2030 estos no llevan
armas atómicas pero sí tienen capacidad
para cargar hasta 40 misiles tomahawk a
raíz de esta Alianza canberra se vio
obligada a abandonar el acuerdo firmado
con Francia en 2016 que estipulaba la
venta de franceses A la nación oceánica
durante 50 años lo que representaba una
pérdida millonaria para el gobierno
francés un hecho que pasó a conocerse
como la crisis de los submarinos
El engaño fue intencionado había más en
juego que el suministro de submarinos
porque se trataba de un acuerdo común
sobre soberanía sellado con la
transmisión de datos altamente
clasificados la forma en la que se
manejaron fue claramente una puñalada
por la espalda
plainley
las asperezas entre Francia y los
miembros de la ucus han sido limadas
desde entonces pero las tensiones se
mantienen con china que ha expresado
rechazo a la transferencia de este tipo
de tecnología Australia en medio de las
tensiones en torno a Taiwán y las
disputas sobre la soberanía en el mar
meridional en casa el Primer Ministro
australiano albanís está bajo presión
por demostrar que este proyecto el más
costoso en la historia del país en
materia de defensa llevará a la
generación de empleo